(audience clapping)
- [Kelly] Have y'all met before?
In anything?
- [John] Yes, we have.
- [Kelly] Oh, you have?
- [Kyra] We did. We did.
- [Kelly] Okay, awesome, awesome.
Well I didn't know if
y'all...sometimes people haven't.
And we like to bring people together.
Um (chuckling), but we
were talking about music.
So you play piano, right?
- I do, yes.
- [Kelly] Like, since you were
a kid, right? Like, little.
- Yeah, over 20 years now.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- [John] Yeah, I also have to say,
you guys were so sweet to
me when I met you guys.
They welcomed me into their home.
And we did this table reading there.
- [Kyra] Aw, that's sweet.
- [Kevin] Yeah. You were
awesome, you were awesome
- [John] You guys are adorable.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's so...
- [Kyra] Yeah, you were. You were great.
- Aw, you guys are so nice.
I have to just quickly tell
a story, which is that,
my dad called me yesterday.
And I told him I was
coming out with you guys.
And he insisted that I
attempt to tell some story
about him auditioning for Footloose?
(all laughing)
- [John] He, like...
- [Kelly] He didn't make the cut?
- He regaled me with this
like seven-minute story.
And was like, make sure you tell that.
I was like, so you want
me to use the entire time.
(all laughing)
(Kyra clapping hands)
- [Kelly] Use my entire segment?
(Kelly laughing and clapping)
- [John] Yes.
- [Kevin] Your only segment.
- [John] Completely about him.
- [Kevin] Tell him to
get your own segment.
(Kelly laughing)
- [John] And then, at
the very end was like,
and make sure you say hi.
(audience chuckling)
- [John] I was like cool.
That's very fitting.
- Ah, so John, now you have this show.
It's called Unstable, which
is the greatest title ever.
So, it's it's with your father.
So, what, is it basically
about y'all's relationship?
- Yeah, it's, it's based
on our relationship.
We, we don't play exactly ourselves.
He plays, uh, sort of an eccentric,
insane biotech engineer entrepreneur.
Kind of Elon Musk-y vibes.
Which, uh, you know is ripe
to make fun of, I think.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(audience chuckling)
- [John] I love the the style of, like,
comedy of manners, and.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [John] Poking fun at the social elites.
And, um, it's very relatable.
That dynamic of a, a parent
that's very, well, annoying.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Yeah.
- [John] Uh, oversteps boundaries.
- Yeah.
- But, but, but their intentions are pure
and they just care.
And our relationship
happens to be sort of unique
in that he's in the public eye
and, and, and, and "beloved".
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so there's not that
many people that agree
with me when I say like, no,
but you don't understand.
He's, he, you can be wildly annoying.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So, when you don't have many people.
- [Kelly] Every parent can, yeah.
- I got a quick pitch for a storyline.
You find out that your dad,
who's the Elon Musk type.
- [John] Yeah.
- Actually, unbeknownst to
you, auditioned for Footloose.
(all laughing)
(Kelly clapping)
- If you, okay.
- And you get to point out the
fact that he didn't get it.
- He didn't get it.
(laughing)
He claims it's 'cause he, like,
blew his knee out in the audition.
(laughing)
Which is like the most Rob thing ever.
- [Kelly] He was going to be amazing.
- He'd be like, I was
crushing it until the minute.
I'm just picturing like he was
seeing people not enjoying it
and he was like, my knee!
(all laughing)
- [John] He is like, get the stretcher.
(Kevin laughing and clapping)
- [Kelly] Oh God.
Your level of wit is incredible, man.
- Thank you.
- [Kevin] That is so funny.
- [Kelly] Oh my God. I love you.